uh yeah what do you want to talk about
now let's do Black Mirror Black Mirror
okay why Black Mirror why Black Mirror
because okay okay before before we start
talking about that yeah do you think if
let's say uh for example like Game of
Thrones has three Banger seasons and
like three dog [ __ ] Seasons that it kind
of levels it out because like Black
Mirror is that well actually before the
later Seasons [ __ ] I'm kidding I'm gonna
go get it
I was about to go bald from the race
she's great because I have bad enough
takes that that would be actually
believable no I wouldn't believe it
no like okay this the British ones again
when it was in our control it was
amazing three was actually pretty good
as well I will say three three I think I
only watched up until three
well I mean season one and two I mean
season two is just oh season two seasons
[ __ ] fantastic White Christmas yeah I
mean I think uh season one and two and
half the season three is like that
that's all the Black Mirror that exists
in my mind but to me Black Mirror is
everything that I look for in a TV show
and I think part of that part of that is
because I just like how much I respect
the original creator of Black Mirror
yeah Charlie Brooker yeah one of my
biggest influences of all time seeing
him seeing him go from like a TV show
where he basically does what I do and
review movies and events and stuff like
that go and see him do Black Mirror was
just such a I actually didn't know it
was fine huh I actually didn't know it
was by Charlie you didn't you didn't
yeah no you didn't no I don't know he's
just incredibly [ __ ] talented
um and just seeing the [ __ ] wild ass
ideas that Black Mirror had in season
one and two and three I mean it kind of
just it it so like accurate that it kind
of mirrors a lot of things that have
happened post the uh oh yeah Post Post
Release right there's a reason why like
Black Mirror is almost like in our
vocabulary with explaining like Tech
that scares us yeah oh yeah everything
is described and it's [ __ ] annoying
but anything that scary and tech oh
that's very Black Mirror it's one of the
most like perfect commentaries I think
yeah of this generation basically it's
yeah it's the it's such a perfect meta
commentary on just the world in general
it is now yeah I use meta right this
time
but uh yeah I don't I don't really know
what else I can say about it I feel like
anything to meant like if tech that
scares you that should be it watch it
don't don't look anything up do not
watch anything go into it you'll have a
great time yeah because if I didn't put
Black Mirror on it's like I I I think
Charlie Brooker took such inspiration
from Twilight Zone right because that's
the only other like goat Anthology
series that I can think of
goatsology did I use ghosts right there
don't follow me that makes sense yeah
because like I it's I I actually really
really [ __ ] love Anthology series oh
yeah yeah when it's done right like I
love death and robots
can we put love can we talk about love
death and robots for a bit because you
need to watch Love death and robots I
think we actually spoke about it on a
podcast not too long ago yeah we
definitely recommended it because it's
so uh because we all watched season
three oh yeah I'll watch season yeah I
feel like Joe watch season three oh okay
yeah we've talked about too much TV no I
mean love death and robots season three
Banger season one Banger season two you
know yeah has Hazard Sparks yeah yeah
season three is really fun season three
is great yeah yeah I just love seeing
the the thing the thing I love about
Anthology series is just seeing so many
different ideas experiments put into one
it's so experimental you know this is
literally the opposite of a show like
you know Breaking Bad you know where
it's just like this is just so many
different ideas that are packed into
different shows and it doesn't need to
be a 10 out of 10 Banger every time
sometimes you have like a little bit of
lull but what I what I appreciate always
an anthology series is that someone has
something to say and they have yeah it's
always fresh yeah and they have one
chance to say it and so it's it's always
like it's always is interesting
especially when they have like when they
have like different directives or
different cinematographers for episodes
yeah completely unique feel to each one
oh yeah yeah exactly I mean like Black
Mirror Has some really iconic episodes
that I think are like must watches yeah
like why Christmas being one like
Christmas amazing yeah uh the [ __ ] uh
my favorite episode of Black Mirror is
probably like the American Idol parody
one the oh that was in season two I
believe yeah [ __ ] I forgot the name of
that episode God I forgot the name of
the episode
I like that one as well with like the
wife who like gets the uh AI yeah oh no
she gets the dead husband and her
husband dies she got a husband like doll
yeah that's like gets her like memories
and he like slowly learns like the post
memories yeah that one's creepy
I can see Japan doing that yeah is that
scary is that scary that I see Japan no
absolutely absolutely that's so Black
Mirror oh the sex toys be like yeah so
so uh you have three left which one do
you want to talk about all right let's
go with Always Sunny first I mean
literally the ghost actually I feel like
Sunny is like the most American Comedy
sitcom yeah and Peep Show is the most
British yeah yeah definitely oh you
wouldn't say Big Bang Theory
you wouldn't say How I Met Your Mother
oh knock them in the middle well I I
realized like watching things like
always sunny and uh Peep Show and
everything like that maybe I just like
to see awful people do awful things 100
it's just like awful people just funny
like exactly I mean that's essentially
what like people show is not to boil it
down and really like the dilute it but
like yeah it's the same awful people but
just British version yeah yeah exactly
and it's just like a lot of a lot of
let's say Peep Show storylines I could
easily see happening in all this sunny
yeah but just like the the dynamic would
be completely oh yeah you know what I
mean right where it's always sunny again
is just uh the five most awful people in
this world just doing awful things and
having awful [ __ ] ideas and trying to
like win in this world it's one of the
funniest sitcoms and long running for a
reason yeah yeah the only reason I think
it's kind of hard to get into is the
first season first four seasons yeah
we're in like a four by three aspect
ratio and look a bit weird yeah oh
really I don't know why also I think the
first season is good but the second
season is when they introduced Danny
DeVito success and that's when it goes
from a good show to a [ __ ] great show
because I think Danny DeVito adds so
much to their chemistry yeah and what I
love about Always Sunny is if you look
at like any of the outtakes and
everything like that is that you can
tell that so much of this is just
[ __ ] improv yeah right there are so
many lines It's Always Sunny that you're
like what where the [ __ ] did this come
from and you know that they just [ __ ]
made it up on this it's so good though
it's so weird I don't think I've
actually sat down and watched like a
full episode oh my God I've seen so many
Clips because it's so [ __ ] iconic and
funny there's like there's so many like
I thought about putting this but it felt
so wrong in no sense because I'm like I
think this is my favorite but there's so
many American sitcoms that didn't like
occupy the same space in my mind like
Arrested Development not the new season
but it's just really [ __ ] funny uh
what are some other really good
Americans who comes that are very adult
humor they're really well written art
community is really good as well your
enthusiasm Curb Your enthusiastic
because it's really good as well yeah I
think Sunny is always sunny is like the
best best out of all of them for me
um yeah I don't know it's just gonna be
sad when it ends up I'm I'm surprised
that it's gone on for this long honestly
well they renewed it for like what two
more seasons I think at least two more
yeah do you think they just did 11 or 10
yeah so I can't remember so many [ __ ]
good meme as well you dumb [ __ ] I love
that one yeah it's just like sometimes
you have you have a moment where you're
watching these people do these awful
things and you're just like [ __ ] do I
kind of relate to what one of the
characters is saying because it's like
that's the problem is it's been a few
characters they are not remotely like
but it's like audience are like I
actually like this guy no no you're not
supposed to you're not supposed to like
them you're like [ __ ] I can actually
like kind of coming I just kind of like
them I mean it's just like it's it's so
it's so awful that it's like [ __ ]
amazing I don't know [ __ ] you have to
watch it uh I will just just watch
always watch any episodes out of context
and I think you'll be all right but I
think that's the thing is like I've only
seen Clips out of content text and it's
still funny yeah yeah exactly because I
think all I think all they do is just
like what would happen if we just put
these four or five characters into a
situation and then they just like let
the characters act out the situation it
kind of feels like an improv class in
some ways right but because they've
worked together so long they kind of
like know each other's beats and
everything like oh yeah like I do not
know how they film some of this without
[ __ ] laughing
all right okay two left let's do
Chernobyl I mean I love this series I
thought about putting it on yeah I was
like I don't know is it because it's too
good it's too good you know how like you
said Breaking Bad is too polished like
this is the most polished and clean TV
show that is just unarguably amazing
when I first saw this and I and I
haven't seen this but when I first saw
pictures of this I thought it was like a
documentary series no yeah uh I mean
yeah I mean I mean it's not a
documentary series but obviously based
on real events yeah you actually believe
that it's based on real events yeah it
is very yeah it's it's one of those
stories oh [ __ ] what happened
yeah bro when when they were writing
Chernobyl in real life bro they they
[ __ ] knew what they did they would
make some great television man yeah yeah
but what I love about shinobu obviously
it's based on real life but it's one of
those stories that happened in real life
that is so [ __ ] insane that it it's
you kind of watch this and you're like
wow this is an insane story oh wait this
actually [ __ ] reality is Stranger Than
Fiction yeah you can't actually believe
that some of the [ __ ] that happened in
Chernobyl actually happened here and
yeah it's just like I said it's just
such a perfectly crafted TV show I think
the reason I've really liked Chernobyl
uh is because it's only like it's a mini
series it's so so short yeah like how
many episodes is it five seconds
oh wow yeah it is it is not much you can
watch it in a day or two
um two evenings it is just amazing you
will not regret okay I think and I don't
know I haven't met a single person who
watched this TV show and didn't sing its
Praises because like the thing the thing
I loved about it is that one one thing
that I normally don't like about let's
say biopics or you know shows about real
life events is that there's nothing
there's nothing to keep me coming back
because I already know the ending
because it happened right yeah because
it happened but it's the journey no no
no like it is about the journey you're
right but sometimes my brain like my
brain is like I need something to keep
me coming back every week yes but I
think with biopics what's so like
interesting and unique about them is
that you can give a lot more context in
a human sense to the events and the
characters involved in a sense yeah yeah
exactly no I also think that's the
reason why a lot of biopics are just
movies yeah right because it's just like
one clean package because you know
what's going to happen most of the time
right but what what like drew me into
Chernobyl immediately and kept me going
to the end that made me appreciate the
journey because the journey was amazing
but the the one thing I think it did
perf ethically was it set up this
mystery right so this power plant
spoilers this power plant basically
explodes in Ukraine [ __ ] alcohol yeah
it's only the most devastating nuclear
disaster in history and within like the
first episode they set up this concept
of this is impossible it is impossible
for a nuclear explosion to happen on
this scale it is so impossible that when
it actually exploded people didn't even
believe that you know it was happening
it was because of the nuclear reaction
right no that's that's that's that's
that was part of like the incompetence
of the uh higher ups back then where
where they were sending people to check
on the nuclear reactor to check on what
caused this explosion and people were
like oh there's [ __ ] bits of nuclear
debris everywhere and they were like I
don't believe you go check yourself and
and so of course everyone who checked
would would die yeah because they would
be exposed to a lethal a lethal dose of
radiation yeah
um and so he sets off this mystery and
that mystery like continues throughout
the entire series and that's what kept
me coming back was just not only just to
see what happened but there was this
mystery that I wanted to see how they
resolve this because I genuinely didn't
know and I genuinely wanted to know
that's just something impossible I feel
Chernobyl the Chernobyl event is one of
those things where everyone knows the
name of it and everyone knows what
happened but very few people actually
know how it happened how or why yeah
it's also really eerie the series like
it it's always really like slow like
kind of violin eerie music that Creeps
in yeah at no point is it even remotely
happy it's like depressing all the way
through yeah and like the cinematography
as well and this isn't [ __ ] fast it
is stunning yeah like watching this is
just a treat all of the actors are
amazing yeah um I think the only thing
that it could do better is it it could
be like maybe it's like a bunch of
British actors so it could be like
Russian to make a little unbelievable I
didn't really need it I felt like it was
just great like yeah you know it was
good it was just like and I think I
think Chernobyl has made like by itself
made me just afraid of just the sound of
a geiger counter there's yeah like the
way they use the geiger counter sounds
you know it's it's it's literally like
scarier than a horror movie yeah right
that is a horror movie yeah exactly
where there's I think there's a scene
where
um these guys are like in like the sewer
or something trying to figure out where
how to get in this nuclear power plant
and the bottom out yeah from the bottom
up right and you see you just hear the
geiger counter and all you hear is the
geiger counter and then since they're
wearing like full suits you don't hear
them say anything you just hear the
breathing and the guide counter and with
those two elements alone they're able to
create such a [ __ ] tense a terrifying
atmosphere and it's just it's just [ __ ]
it's insane amazing television you will
not regret it